[Music]
so here's my day I wake up I immediately
go to my appointment at the chiropractor
to get an adjustment because I have to
do that from time to time because I'm
apparently 75 years old I'm printing out
my passes for my Godzilla screening
tonight which I'm extremely excited
about and then I see that Zack Snyder
has tweeted out a photo of the Batmobile
and in front of the Batmobile stands Ben
Affleck in his bat suit
and I said to myself in all honesty guys
I was extremely excited to see that
because if you don't know I'm a huge
Batman fan and you probably knew that
because Batman he is my favorite
comic-book character I've always liked
him I watched the 60s Adam West show and
I was young I grew up with the Tim
Burton films in the animated series I
lived through the Schumacher films yeah
I actually that happened that happened
in real life and I experienced the
awesomeness that was the Dark Knight
trilogy and I'm extremely excited to see
what Zack Snyder does with his character
and I'm truly hoping that his film is as
good as this looks I love his new suit
it looks beautiful it looks very much
like Frank Miller's take from The Dark
Knight Returns if you have not read that
do so it is basically one of Batman's
best outings ever to be put on paper
definitely check out that if you haven't
and it definitely seems inspired by that
particularly in the cowl the shorter
ears are very much so inspired by Frank
Miller's drawings some people are
complaining the ears a little too short
they look a little too stubby a little
too cartoony I just see Frank Miller's
artistry and that makes me extremely
happy as a huge fan of Batman it's a
comic book film related announcement
there's going to be screaming in the
streets and bloody murder everyone's
gonna want it to be exactly the way that
they envisioned it from their childhood
or whatever which way they feel it would
be the best but I honestly am extremely
pleased with the way this looks because
it looks quite like Frank Miller's
creation and I think that's awesome
because his portrayal of Batman was a
very very gritty and older kind of
grizzled getting a little bit tired he's
been doing it for a while and that's
something that I really think is gonna
be cool to see because we have not
actually seen that we saw it sort of in
the Dark Knight Rises but for the most
part we have not seen Batman say in his
40s and I think we're about to let's be
a little realistic here because I am a
film critic and as a film critic I am
supposed to be critical and add a little
of filmmaking and whatnot and that's my
job I'm really hoping this film is as
good as this image looks I have my
doubts about how it can turn out because
Zack Snyder didn't make a perfect movie
with Man of Steel you may like it you
may hate it but I think everyone can
admit that it wasn't incredible you know
what I mean like even people who liked
it were like that was really good I
really enjoyed it but no one really
thought it was the best movie ever made
and I'm really hoping that he learns
from some of the mistakes he made on Man
of Steel with this new Batman vs
Superman film because this is the most
epic assemblage of DC characters we have
had ever in a film and I am truly hoping
that it delivers what do you guys think
of this image what do you think of Ben
Affleck as Batman are you hoping that
it's gonna be great because I am I'm
really really counting on him and I
actually do have a lot of confidence in
Ben Affleck because as a filmmaker he's
really proved himself too seriously know
what he's doing behind the camera and he
has really changed his entire career
around and I'm hoping that this
continues in that path because he's
already kind of bit the big one in
regards to portraying a comic-book
character in film with daredevil and I
think he's learned from his lessons and
I'm really hoping that's true and then
with Batman vs Superman we get an
incredible comic book film
let's hope thanks so much for watching
as always guys I'm interested in hearing
your thoughts below in the comments and
as always thank you so much and if you
like this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes
[Music]